Nursing can be surprising in the fact that
you don't realize how much of a person's life,
psycho-social, nutrition, everything ties
into their health status and nursing is really
about taking everything that's about that
person's life and putting it into care.
I chose the University of Arizona's College of
Nursing because of it's hands on curriculum.
Within the skills lab, we're really
able to simulate a real life experience
so we have mannequins with computers,
we can actually set vital signs,
we can set heart sounds, lung sounds,
bodily functions, communication,
and it really provides a very real life
experience for the students as much as possible.
In a simulation setting when students encounter
a situation that's stressful and high pressure,
occasionally people do freeze up.
That's okay.
That's alright.
That's part of the learning experience.
Our students are able to go right next door
to the University of Arizona medical center
and they're a part of the research and the
medical care provided at this excellent center.
We offer them a multitude of different areas
of care from the pediatrics to the adults
to neuro-patients to oncology patients and I
think the more opportunities they have to care
for different kind of patients the more
of a well rounded nurse they will be.
The skills are a vital portion
of what the students need
to learn as they go through the courses.
He's one of those teachers that if you don't
understand something he can retell it 50
different ways until you get it.
There are other aspects of
nursing that they gain.
It's becoming confident and
proud of what you're doing.
Becoming a nurse is extremely
a prideful profession.
We're trusted by all and the
students need to learn this.
I think they learn it through
example, it's not something
that I can take to a classroom and teach you.
I look at it as we're caring for a person
as opposed to we are caring for a diagnosis.
I'm actually an honors student, working on an
honor's thesis and so I've been able to go out
and interact with nurses in the field
I'm looking at which is school nursing
and teem pregnancy prevention so
they've set up opportunities for me
but I wouldn't have been able to get myself
if it hadn't been for the help of the faculty.
I'm gonna go and present my
research to the Western Institute
of Nursing which it's incredible.
I never thought I'd be able to do that.
I just feel so empowered and
able to make people feel better,
it touches your heart every time they say, you
know the nurses are what makes the difference
in my treatment and you know that the way
you care for someone has a direct impact
on their recovery or if they're
terminal, making the end of life
as comfortable for them as possible.
I feel confident that with the skills I
have and with the skills I'm going to get,
I will be the best nurse
I can be and the College
of Nursing has really prepared me for that.